hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast clinical next-generation
sequencing for precision cancer
therapeutics I am Brenda Kelly Kim of
lab roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event lab roots is leading
scientific social networking site we are
proud to bring you this interactive web
seminar for more information please
visit us at wwe.com we have a few
important announcements before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit your questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to get to as many of your
questions as we can you can enlarge the
slide window by clicking on the screen
icon in the lower right hand corner of
the slide window if you have any
technical problems viewing or hearing
this presentation properly please let us
know by clicking on the support button
at the top right of your presentation
window or submit your problems for the
green Q&A button lower left this
presentation has been approved for
continuing educational credit please
click on the c/e button at the bottom
left corner and follow the process to
receive your credits I would now like to
introduce today's speaker dr. Christina
Lockwood dr. Lockwood joined the
department of laboratory medicine as an
associate director of the genetics and
solid tumor diagnostics laboratory at
the University of Washington Medical
Center in 2014 she is board certified by
the American Board of clinical chemistry
the american board of medical genetics
and genomics after obtaining her PhD the
University of Wisconsin dr. Lockwood
completed postdoctoral fellowship
training in clinical chemistry and
clinical molecular genetics at the
Washington University School of Medicine
in st. Louis her interests include the
development and application of molecular
methods the detection of genomic
alterations and genetic disease
hematologic malignancies and solid
tumors dr. Lockwood has also been active
in the design and implementation of
educational resources related to
training and genomic met
I will now turn it over the dr. Lockwood
for her presentation thanks very much
Brenda for that kind introduction it's
my pleasure to join with you this
morning as we are going to be talking
about clinical next-generation
sequencing and specifically in the realm
of precision cancer therapeutics which
has been quite an exciting advent in our
clinical laboratory medicine toolkit if
you will so we'll start with some
learning objectives for today we'll talk
specifically about the clinical utility
of precision genomics describe the
advantages that clinical next-generation
sequencing offers as well as summarizing
different general types of
next-generation sequencing assays and
this is really in broad categories and
as we go through the presentation that
will make a little bit more sense so a
recent New England Journal of Medicine
editorial piece highlighted precision
medicine and specifically called out
three areas saying that it's
personalized it's problematic and it's
promising which I think summarizes quite
well I've added an additional bullet
point to that which is that it's also
practical so this is going to be our
outline for today so some physicians
have had really questioned whether we
should be calling this personalized
medicine or precision medicine because
they really feel that medicine has in
fact been personalized for generations
and that's true in the sense that
treatment has been tailored to a
specific patient often when we're
talking about precision medicine we're
talking about integrating not only
biochemical markers for really also
integrating genetic and genomic markers
to tailor a treatment to a specific
patient and we'll go through again some
of these examples I want to highlight
that precision medicine does extend
beyond genomics so some examples are
shown here for example in hyperlipidemia
when we're looking at LDL cholesterol
the treatment there would be a statin
therapy and in HIV and AIDS where we're
looking at cd4 t-cell counts to assess
viral load that would be then
antiretroviral therapy and pediatric
cancer where you have an example acute
plastic leukemia you abusing high-dose
methotrexate and in therapeutic drug
monitoring for example to do leucovorin
rescue and then in lung cancer if you
have an EML for elk fusion that would
indicate the crizotinib therapy would be
relevant for a patient so again this
really does extend beyond just genetics
and genomics but that's meant one advent
that has highlighted the utility of
precision medicine when we're looking
specifically it's somatic genomics
precision therapeutics can really be
guided by looking for specific genomic
alterations and so if you look at the
patient population shown at the top here
so if you have cancer patients that are
either metastatic or have recurrent or
metastatic disease or that have incident
disease there's a mixture of patients
those who have genomic alterations as
well as those who do not have shown the
cultivation so first looking at the
patients who don't have genomic
alterations you want to specifically
identify those patients because they're
not going to be responsive to a putative
therapy you want to identify them early
so that you can put them on another
treatment that will in fact potentially
be effective for them these these not
only are these drugs expensive but they
do in fact have side effects and so we
really want to maximize the therapeutic
benefit and then in patients where we
can identify genomic alterations you
want to specifically match them to a
targeted therapy so it's important to
recognize that it's not only that you
have a mutation that's important and
precision Don therapeutics but it's just
as important to not have an alteration
in to figure that out early on in the
process so that you can find the most
effective treatment for that patient and
so the Human Genome Project used Sanger
sequencing and this is something that
you may or may not have heard of as far
as Sanger sequencing specifically is
concerned it's been really the standard
of care in in genetics and genomic
research since 1975 when Frederick
Sanger published the paper that
discussed what exactly Sanger sequencing
is so saying your sequence
at best i'll say can sequence up to a
thousand bases per reaction so that's it
in a single continuous stretch you can
sequence up to a thousand bases many
graduate students including myself I'd
we're really not consistently able to
see a thousand bases may be more in the
range of five to six hundred basis /
reaction but at best you could get a
thousand basis for reaction it's a
single molecule at a time that your
sequencing and again it has been widely
used since 1975 and this was the
technology that was used for the Human
Genome Project and so that that project
was an international consortium it costs
about three billion dollars to sequence
3 billion base pairs of DNA so it's it's
quite expensive to sequence by Sanger
sequencing but that was really the
standard and there was some automated
technology that was introduced during
the course of human genome project that
made that process be a little bit faster
than originally anticipated which is
exciting is always good to complete a
project more quickly than anticipated
but it still did take quite a number of
years and so one of the advantages that
has come out of the human genome project
is that we now have this huge library of
of our genome the human genome and this
is a public area picture that is from
the Welcome Institute the medicine now
collection and then I love it's actually
a printout of the human human genome and
you can see there's a close-up here of
one of these books so it's / chromosome
you can see at the top so if we look at
3.4 billion units of DNA code that's how
many nucleotides we have on our genome
so that would be one hundred and twenty
seven volumes if we have a thousand
pages per volume and that print would be
size five font and you can't really see
very well but that 880 C and G that's
size 5 font so it's quite a lot of DNA
that we're talking about and I use that
really to illustrate the point that with
next-generation sequencing this presents
a new challenge relative to what we were
doing by saying your sequencing so with
Sanger sequencing your
directing your sequencing effort really
to a specific question where's with
next-generation sequencing it's a little
bit more challenging in order for us to
to pull out what you're specifically
looking for to talk very briefly about
next-generation sequencing terminology
there's a lot of different terms that
are used so typically first generation
sequencing is saying your sequencing
whereas with next-generation sequencing
NGS is I'll abbreviate throughout the
talk that's also termed massively
parallel sequencing or high-throughput
sequencing relative to sanger sequencing
then it also becomes second generation
sequencing and there are newer platforms
available that are third generation
sequencing or single molecule sequencing
and so again there's specific
technologies that are used in each of
these different categories but for the
purposes of our talk on these all of
these terms under the bullet
next-generation sequencing or NGS can
really be used essentially synonymously
so the National Human Genome Research
Institute NHGRI publishes this figure
which you may have seen before and it's
a really good illustration so I think
that most people are familiar with the
fact that sequencing costs have have
reduced over time and that's what excuse
me what that's what this figure is
showing and it's the green is
specifically showing the cost per genome
this is per human genome and the white
line is Moore's law and so this is in a
really an amazing feat of technology in
the field of computing so Moore's law is
the observation that the number of
transistors in computing hardware is
doubled approximately every two years
and that's essentially held true since
the 1960s so that's really been an
amazing progress in infield of computing
and so this is almost a little
tongue-in-cheek for next-generation
sequencing relative to Moore's law and
you can see in skiing that here is where
we see an approximate inflection point
so sequencing costs were significant
we decreased relatives to their about
2007-2008 and then we see this
precipitous decline relative to that in
even we see again in 2015 there's
another precipitous decline and really
what this is reflecting is the advent of
next-generation sequencing so it had a
significant effect in and what we're
able to produce / sequencing reaction
and it's really driving the cost of the
genome down to the very close to the
thousand-dollar point per genome it's
important to mention that's reagent cost
not necessarily interpretation cost so
if we vary at the broad level very
basically compares Sanger sequencing and
next-generation sequencing there's
advantages that each method has and so
I've called out to specific platforms
here just for the purposes of
illustration if we think about accuracy
Sanger sequencing wins so it's about
tenfold higher per base with Sanger
sequencing relative to next-generation
sequencing the throughput we have a
significant advantage in next-generation
sequencing through foot and then the
amount of time per run at this point
Sanger sequencing is still faster even
if you're doing 96 capillaries at a time
which is what we can do with some of
these automated technologies the read
length is about 44 fold higher with
Sanger sequencing so next-generation
sequencing produces a lot of very short
fragments relative to what you get with
singer the cost per megabase is
significantly higher with Sanger
sequencing and again this is what's
really was reflected in the graph that
we just were looking at so it's about
eight thousand fold higher by saying or
sequencing the next generation
sequencing and there is a higher
investment cost with next-generation
sequencing that's something that we will
continue to see I think decline as we
have more companies that are entering
the marketplace and if we think about
what genetic assays really look like
they can range from genetic up to
genomic and so I've shown this was you
know going from single site that would
be with
single base pair here all the way up to
genomic which is if we were looking at
the entire human genome and perhaps a
little bit more fun to think about it is
is relative to ice cream cones if you
will so a single site if you're looking
again just at a single base pair change
and then looking at a continuum from a
partial gene somewhere in the 100 base
pair range up to different types of
panels and Exum is the the coding
sequence so the protein coding sequence
of our genome and then of course the
genome would be the entire human genome
and I've called out some specific
examples here so a single site relative
to a cancer change would be like if you
have a beer after on 600 mutation so
often in the case of melanoma you would
be looking at that specific mutational
profile thinking about partial gene or
genes for example in cystic fibrosis
screening where we're for carrier
screening typically looking at 23
mutations and then again there's hotspot
panels comprehensive panels and then
extending up to XOM in genome so it's
typically not a hundred percent but
often when you get to something that's
called a hotspot panel that next
generation sequencing really has both
utility and cost effectiveness so you
need to be looking at more than just a
few base pairs or just a partial gene
again not a hundred percent but often
before a next-generation sequencing
starts to become cost effective and
we'll look at some more examples of what
that specifically is again as we go a
little bit more in depth so going back
to our outline we've talked a little bit
a little bit about the personalization
but let's talk about the practicalities
so next-generation sequencing is
clinically offered in diagnostic
laboratories around the world today so
it is in fact already in the clinic and
there's a lot of utility in thinking
about assays from a multigene
perspective so historically we've done
really single gene testing
and so when we're doing that we're
looking at a limited region so you want
to look specifically at a single base
pair change by definition then it's
narrowly targeted and that result may
trigger additional gene testing so based
on whether you get a positive or
negative in your first gene you may go
on to do a second third or fourth gene
if you compare it and contrast that with
multiple gene testing you're looking at
all relevant genes and again to focus on
cancer we would be looking at nessas not
necessarily all relevant cancer genes
for particular cancer diagnosis but
really doing potentially a pan-cancer
assay and that's what's shown here where
you'd be looking at b-raf egfr KS with
three kits in npm1 so simultaneously you
detect a mutation status of all of these
genes and that's really a paradigm shift
from how we've traditionally done this
it is cost effective it's efficient in
that you save time and really important
is that it's tissues sparing
particularly as we move in the field of
oncology towards smaller and smaller
biopsies and you've probably heard
liquid biopsies but but even in the
solid tumor realm to think about fine
needle aspirates and other very small
pieces of tissue that we acquire we
really don't have enough tissue to go
from one asset to the necra to the next
so if we can have one assay that
incorporates really all of the relevant
mutations for that cancer type that's
very powerful and then it can this type
of testing can certainly yield
unexpected findings and we'll look at
some examples of that I have some case
examples that we'll we'll discuss and
it's important to think about that both
in the realm that it can produce
unexpected findings that you expect so
mutations and other cancer genes as well
as mutations that you don't necessarily
expect you can find alterations that
maybe are actually associated with the
germline and again we'll talk a little
bit more about that so there's a recent
review paper that highlights some of the
different technologies that are used for
next-generation sequencing
and so there's a lot that's actually on
this slide so we'll talk a little bit of
in-depth about it the time is what's
shown across the x-axis from 2004 to now
and then on the y-axis we see the
Machine output and this is sequence in
mega bases okay and then for reference
the 100 x x own versus a 30x genome are
shown as well and so there's two that
there's a number of different companies
and that's what's shown in by the color
of each circle it's a little hard to see
but there are inside the circle there's
a number what that number is reflecting
is the base pairs per next generation
sequencing read that you get so you can
see that they range from from very small
so for example here we have 35 base
pairs up to very large so with the
Oxford nanopore we get six thousand base
pairs potentially / sequencing read but
most next-generation sequencing
platforms really give you a very small
so and the one to 200 to 300 possibly
base pairs per sequencing read and there
are two platforms that are predominant
in the clinical laboratories and those
are the Illumina platform and the ion
torrent which is actually now on by
thermo Fisher and so those are what are
the dots that are in red and the dots
that are in blue here just for reference
again because those are predominant in
the clinical laboratories today the
general workflow for next-generation
sequencing varies with from one platform
to another but particularly when we're
thinking about those technologies that
are dominant in clinical laboratories it
starts with template preparation that
can be either DNA or RNA which is an
important point to emphasize that you
can in fact start with RNA if you're
doing RNA seek from there you do
massively parallel sequencing which both
the Ion Torrent and the alumina use
clonal amplification and that's followed
by
by some form some form of detection
whether that's imaging or detecting a pH
change and then data analysis follows
that which involves genome alignment and
assembly and of course more
sophisticated analysis depending on what
the specific application is the read
alignments are really the raw data if
you think about next-generation
sequencing so we'll spend a minute here
to look at this down at the bottom is
the reference sequence and so this is
showing a flit 3 which is an important
gene involved in cancer specifically in
AML has prognostic significance so the
reference genome these tiny little lines
that I just show up is different colors
so when we do next generation sequencing
we aligned back to the reference genome
and what we get are a number of
different individual sequencing reads
eel here and so that's what's shown in
all of these little blue bars are the
sequencing reads and then at the top is
the aggregate coverage and this is what
is shown in the gray so that is the
coverage that we're getting and you can
see that the more blue bars that we have
for an area the higher coverage we have
so this is also often called on the
depth of coverage when people are
talking about sequencing so it's really
it's relative to how many sequencing
reads we have at a particular locus and
so what we're talking about is you know
that you would have many cancer essays
tend to have in the range of 500 reads
per sequence base see about over the
entire essay range you have on average
five hundred reads per sequence locus
and so in cancer diagnostics or even in
constitutional changes there's a number
of different types of variants that
exists so they range from a single base
substitution and again I'm using vrf as
an example where you have a v600e change
again that's very prev
in melanoma you can have small in dells
in dell stands for insertion deletion we
just abbreviate that within del Sol in
lung cancer for example we see exon 19
deletions in egfr and then you can have
medium-sized in dells that are typically
referred to as less than five hundred
base pairs large in dells are those that
are greater than five hundred base pairs
an example of that is if you
specifically have an exon deletion for
example in tp53 that's associated with
leaf romania syndrome of the cancer
predisposition syndrome copy number
variants are typically referred to as
those changes that are greater than a
thousand base pairs and so for example
we have met amplification that occurs in
multiple different cancer types and then
structural variants are highly variable
in in size for example a translocation
and one example of that would be EML for
elk which is a recurrent mutation that
occurs in lung cancer cases so it's
important to recognize that variants
come do in fact come in all shapes and
sizes because the way that we detect
these when we're doing our
next-generation sequencing assays is
different so for basically each type of
change you need to have a different
bioinformatics solution in order to pull
it out the powerful piece of this is
that one assay can actually determine
all of these things but it's really and
how you analyze the data determines
whether you can you can pull out
individual aspects of each of these
changes so currently there are a number
of clinical applications of
next-generation sequencing that are
commercially available and so those
range from somatic specifically in
cancer of course to inherited disorders
and that's really a wide array of thing
so cancer predisposition there are a
number of assays for different types of
mutations that are grouped by
pathogenesis or even exome for example
if you have
a seemingly Mendelian disorder but you
can't identify the mutation that's
underlying that there's also a
non-invasive prenatal testing and so
that's using next-generation sequencing
by most commercial assays and then
there's even more exciting microbial
identification and this is where we're
starting to do next generation
sequencing to specifically pull out
bacterial viral and other pathogens
specifically looking for for their
genome and the the computational side of
that is quite challenging but but it's
very exciting that this is something
that's now commercially available so
when you're thinking about an assay
design whether you would be looking on a
genome level or doing smaller scale
really depends on the clinical need so
for non-invasive prenatal testing or
microbial identification whole genome
sequencing is is really the best choice
for that because you need low coverage
so you don't need to sequence each base
a lot of time but you really need a
sense across the genome so for example a
non-invasive prenatal testing it's
important that you're picking up all of
chromosome 21 at low coverage but you
really want to see all of chromosome 21
to assess whether you have trisomy 21
for example for Down syndrome for
inherited disorders often that's exome
sequencing so again it's fairly low
coverage but it's across all of the
coding sequence of the human genome and
then if we're thinking about
specifically for somatic testing this is
really tends to be what's called
targeted sequencing and the coverage is
much higher that's important because in
somatic sequencing we need to be able to
detect both see the germline and the
cancer so those coexist in a single
specimen so we get a biopsy specimen
that has not a hundred percent cancer
cells so we have a mixture of cells in
that targeted sequencing can be either
comprehensive so determining really all
of the relevant cancer genes at once or
it could be looking at hot spots and so
for example
that we're only pulling out the
mutations that we know are very
important either in a single cancer type
or in multiple cancer types so I have a
single case example here that will look
at over a couple different slides so
this is a patient with advanced lung
adenocarcinoma he's a 71 year old male
with metastatic lung adenocarcinoma and
that was diagnosed in february2014 and
so he had a poor response to first light
in chemotherapeutics and if you look at
the NCCN guidelines what they recommend
is to do molecular profiling for this
patient in this context in order to
guide treatment right so he's already
received the standard of care didn't
have a good response to that and in
order to choose a subsequent therapy
they recommend doing molecular profile
to really help assess what treatment
would be most helpful for that patient
and part of the reason that they
recommend doing molecular profiling is
is it shown in this slide so recurrent
mutations that you see in lung
adenocarcinoma are really quite
extensive so they range from you know k
rest is one of the most common things
that the mutations that you'll see and
that actually indicates that you would
not respond to typical tyrosine kinase
inhibitor treatments but there's a
number of other mutations as well so
egfr also has a fairly large piece of
the puzzle or piece of the pie here but
there's a number of additional
alterations to our very low frequency
events but nonetheless our recurrently
mutated and often have associated
therapies so that's one of the reasons
that again molecular profiling is
particularly prevalent in lung
adenocarcinoma and that's what the mtcn
recommends so we'll come back to this
case casing yet after we look it a
little bit more depth what type of fas
there are available so in profiling
assays there's very broad division we
typically refer to them as hotspot
assays and comprehensive essays so I've
listed some specific
samples and then just a pictorial
representation of what a hot spot si
would be so in this case where you you
know again you're specifically pulling
out particular mutations that you know
our recurrence and important in a cancer
type so what that gives you is maybe an
incomplete picture but but you can you
can tell from this picture that this is
a boat right you can't necessarily tell
for example that there's a flag hanging
off of the back of the boat from the
first picture but you could get a
general sense with a comprehensive assay
and again I've shown some some examples
here what you get is a more complete
view of the cancer type because you're
it depends on how you've designed the
essay but typically what you're trying
to do is really to identify all
mutations in the relevant cancer genes
because those can fact have important
significance for selecting the specific
therapy for our patients so just it a
very broad level to compare hotspot
sequencing and comprehensive sequencing
in turn around time hotspot sequencing
is definitely faster that partially
reflects how the DNA is prepared even
before you do the sequencing but even
after you finish the sequencing the the
downstream analysis side of that is
definitely faster at this point you do
need less sample when you're doing
hotspot sequencing then relative to
comprehensive sequencing but there have
been some important advances that we've
seen in the library preparation so this
will continue to I think be something
that will see improve over time single
nucleotide changes can really accurately
and adequately be assessed with either
method I put up plus minus for hotspot
sequencing just in that you have to
specifically design your assay to detect
whatever mutation you're thinking about
where's with comprehensive sequencing
again you would you would already detect
these and so for for small in dells
that's typically something that you can
see with hotspot sequencing but then
when we get into copy number changes or
structural variant changes like gene
fusions that's something where
comprehensive sequencing has a signet
advantage the informatik analysis is
significantly easier if we're doing
hotspot sequencing then incomprehensive
sequencing but the ident of the ability
to identify novel variants is definitely
easier with comprehensive sequencing and
then cost is lower with hotspot
sequencing as as you may expect so to go
back to our case example with these you
know two broad types of sequencing
assays so this patient has you know
advanced lung adenocarcinoma and so
there's all these different types of
mutations at this point the the hotspot
assays aren't able to detect the
rearrangements that are shown in red
boxes so in this context it's probably
one of the most cost-effective ways to
start to look for changes for this
patient that would again change his
specific treatment plan would be to do a
comprehensive sequencing essay so let's
talk about some of the challenges in
limitations that arise from from doing
clinical next-generation sequencing one
important question I think is is to ask
is more always better so when we're
thinking about large sequencing panels
it we can do more but does that actually
have a clinical benefit so some of the
challenges are the interpretation is
significantly more challenging in order
to be able to detect these multiple
types of changes that takes longer both
for the bioinformatics as well as for
the analysis the turnaround time is
definitely longer at least in the US the
reimbursement is is definitely something
that's still evolving in this field so
there's not universal acceptance by
different pairs of the cpt codes that
are used and then you can have secondary
or incidental findings and that's when
you find something that you weren't
specifically looking for in your assay
and there's a lot of different types of
things that can be found but the
advantages include that this is in fact
comprehensive which leads to at least a
higher hit rate for diagnostic and or
actionable
tations and that's important for driving
both clinical trials and and discovery
in typically it depends on the specific
tests that we're talking about but
they're typically priced such that it's
cost effective if your sequencing more
than three genes relative to doing it at
individually so this this large panel
for example a panel that we do sequences
more than 250 genes so if you were going
to do individually three or more genes
in this context getting more than 250
it's actually you know significantly
cost-effective its cost the same to get
our panel as to get three individual
genes but these assays are laboratory
developed tests and as such they really
have to be rigorously validated and
there's there's still not as much
guidance is there otherwise could be so
really early adopters some of the
professional societies and regulatory
agencies do provide guidance but it's
not as is strong will say as some of the
guidance that you get in other areas of
the clinical laboratory and it's
definitely an area that they've
continuing to evolve relative to be the
FDA for example for laboratory developed
tests and it's important to recognize
that a number of different types of
variants are poorly or not detected by
current next-generation sequencing
either the platform or the pipeline and
it's really both together that you have
to consider when thinking about the
clinical need so substitutions and small
in dells are not that challenging for us
to detect by next-generation sequencing
and that's really irrespective of the
platform but once we start to get into
larger insertions and deletions copy
number variants and structural variants
electrodes locations that's that's
definitely much more challenging and
some platforms aren't able to detect us
at all so that's again something that
has to be really carefully validated in
a clinical context and I put up here the
central dogma of molecular biology going
from DNA to
RNA to protein to really emphasize that
what we're looking at if we're doing
next generation sequencing from DNA is
we will see a DNA change if you have a
change this downstream of DNA that of
course changes whether you're expressing
a protein that's not something that we
would be able to detect with current
methods and there's a number of
bioinformatics challenges that arise
from next-generation sequencing and
what's shown here is really some of the
important interpretation piece of this
so this is an example of a tp53
frameshift deletion and that's what this
black bar is is showing you a deletion
in NT p53 and so in this case we had 500
reads at this particular base and 56 of
the 500 showed this deletion tp53 is an
important cancer gene so you may think
that you know this is again an important
change that we're seeing is really
contributing to the patient's cancer
type but we have in our laboratory and
internal at a specific frequency
database and so across all of our essays
that we've done we see this mutation in
eighty-two percent of our cases right
and so it's what that's telling us is
that this is an analytical artifact it's
not contributing to the patient's cancer
because we see again this is an
eighty-two percent of the cases and so
there's it's really important that you
have this built into your pipeline to be
able to detect these recurrent artifacts
because the error profiles
next-generation sequencing is
significantly higher than what we see
with some other technologies like Sanger
sequencing in one way that we're able to
get this sensitivity that's really
important for the clinical context is
through parallelization and so I'm using
that term to release to emphasize that
different bioinformatics tools for
example different variant callers really
have different strengths and so stacking
multiple approaches into a
pipeline can significantly improve your
sensitivity so in this example we have
the variant caller 1 over here that
detects a certain number of mutations
and then the variant collar over here
that also detects a certain number of
mutations but you can see that it's not
an overlapping Venn diagram right so we
have some that are only called vibrant
color 1 and then we have others that are
only called by variant color 2 and what
that leads to really are different
strengths and limitations of each so we
have some variant colors that have a
high degree of sensitivity and so what
that high sensitivity means is that we
have a number of true positives but we
also get cases like here where we have a
false positive where is for example by
variant color too we have a color that's
high specificity so we're not
necessarily detecting all the changes
that are there but we have almost all
the changes that we identify are
actually true positives and so it's
really the intersection of these two
that can provide significant benefit on
a clinical assay the way that we
approach this in our laboratory is to
stack both variant color 1 and variant
color to return all the data to the
director and then really use our
clinical expertise in filtering that
list down in assessing whether a change
is clinically significant or not or some
sort of an analytical artifact and
that's that's how we avoid reporting
false positives but it is definitely a
manual process so the the clinical
reporting model that we use at the
University of Washington is quite
integrated so we start with multiple
multi-disciplinary team that contributes
to the panel design and so then we have
once that implemented the data analysis
and mutation identification is something
that occurs in the laboratory and then
we have a consensus team that really
interprets each case and so that
includes laboratory directors clinicians
and genetic counselors laboratory
genetic counselors
the report is specifically written by
the lab director entered into the
medical record and then this last piece
is particularly important where we
assess the treatment and response and
then we feed that back so it's a
constantly evolving process of knowing
what the changes that are identified in
a clinical sequencing case really mean
in the in the clinical context for a
specific patient so again it's an
iterative process and so incidental or
secondary findings are really a
hot-button issue if you will so the
American College of medical genetics and
genomics hid issued recommendations
around this topic in 2013 and really
recommended an in this initial
publication that all clinical exome and
genome sequencing should report back
from this minimum list of 56 genes in
both adults and children so if you
identified mutations in these jeans they
really needed to be reported back and
they were specifically advocating a
proactive search if you will so if you
were sequencing let's say the cancer
predisposition gene brca1 even if you
weren't pulling out mutations but if
your assay was able to sequence that
gene that you proactively went in search
for whether those mutations there are
not and reported that back to patients
and this was extremely contentious so
you can see in a fairly short period of
time that article had a number of
citations and ACMG did update that
recommendation in 2014 to allow patients
and physicians to opt out but it's
definitely a field that's continuing to
evolve and as I mentioned the
contentious at best so let's talk about
some specific promising examples that
we've seen a rise out of clinical
next-generation sequencing so if we
focus on lung cancer and that's remember
the clinical vignette that we've used
previously so this is one comprehensive
cancer si there are others that have
shown similar findings but across
over 500 cases what we found was that
there was an actionable variant that was
identified in almost half of the cases
and that's it was similar across all
cancer types but we've called out lung
cancer just because we have a lot of
cases in this initial cohort it's really
important to emphasize that when you're
thinking about the yield of a test it
really depends on what your definition
of actionability is so some publications
will use the the definition of action
ability as that you just find any
recurrent mutations so if you find a
tp53 mutations for example in lung
cancer that's not actionable you're not
going to treat a patient differently
based on that mutation with a definition
that was used in this particular
publication but other publications do
use that so it's just something
important to keep in mind when you're
thinking about what you know
quote-unquote actionability really does
mean you know k r s it does tell you for
example not to use a specific treatment
that's that's how it's being used in
this publication importantly we can
identify mutations but this was really a
seminal study in saying we can identify
mutations but it actually has a
significant clinical impact so on what
we see and this is again in non-small
cell lung cancer so if patients were
were if they had sequencing so if they
had clinical sequencing that's what's
shown in either the the darker blue or
green here so on the head sequencing but
there was there was no targeted therapy
but over here if they did have a
targeted therapy versus those where if
no driver was was actually identified so
what you see is if you do sequencing and
there's a matched therapy that a patient
is able to be put on they had a
significant advantage as far as over
overall survivability so again that this
does in fact have clinical benefit to do
molecular profiling in this patient
population
so going back to this case the net that
we've used a few times remember this is
a 71 year old male who has metastatic
lung adenocarcinoma that was diagnosed
in february2014 he had a poor response
to the standard of care first-line
chemotherapy dicks he had a
comprehensive next-generation sequencing
tests it was performed in March of 2014
and this is the mutational profile that
we that we know exists in lung
adenocarcinoma that's why in this
context they selected a comprehensive
next-generation sequencing essay and so
what we found in this patient was a
mutation in Anna met gene and the
specifics is shown here and the expected
this mutation is that on the protein
half-life is increased so that we've
additional to higher levels of met
activity excuse me and so when that
signaling pathway is overactive on what
we know is that crizotinib is an
effective treatment to use and so that
was used in this patient and he
tolerated it well and 47 days after
therapy was was initiated he had a
follow-up CT and the radiology report
specifically said there was a
substantial interval decrease in the
lung metastases and he had a continued
response at 90 days post initiation by
CT he's at this point being followed by
his community oncologist so I don't have
follow-up cps after that but that was
you know definitely a benefit that this
patient received and really wouldn't
have gotten without doing a
comprehensive cancer sequencing essay so
looking at another context is in
clinical trials so in this context we
have a 58 year old female she has
recurrence metastatic breast cancer and
it's both estrogen receptor and
progesterone receptor positive she was
diagnosed and treated in two thousand
and then they ordered tumor sequencing
for treatment after she had recurrence
over ten years after her initial
treatment and what we saw was that there
was fgr fgfr1 amplification that was
and this is showing us specifically how
we look at our copy number variants and
so on this axis we have the chromosome
and then the number of gene copies are
shown over here and we have specifically
blocked out boxed out fgfr1 because we
do see amplification of that gene so she
was enrolled in an fgfr1 inhibitor
clinical trial and again this is one of
the advantages of doing comprehensive
next-generation sequencing we can detect
really all of the mutations that are
important and that can really further
clinical trials in discovery and
development of new treatments and so
it's really patients who are treatment
refractory who may have the most benefit
from doing comprehensive sequencing so
this is a 56 year old female who was an
effort smoker he presented to her
primary care provider with an S neck
mass and they identified poorly
differentiated lung adenocarcinoma that
was unfortunately metastatic already at
stage for a time of presentation and
that's again unfortunately not an
uncommon occurrence that we see in lung
cancer so often these patients are
presenting later in their courses in
their course of disease and so they
ordered tumor sequencing for treatments
because she was so advanced at the time
in what we identified was a raw Swan
gene fusion and if you if you have to
have lung cancer I guess I would have to
say that this is the best kind that you
you know if I could choose this is the
kind I would choose so Ross one has a
specific targeted therapy that you can
use in this context the restaurant
inhibitor was initiated right away it
was well tolerated in and so two and a
half years later the patient is stable
there's no signs or symptoms of her lung
and a carcinoma and you know she she
works full time owns her own business
and her new goal is to be certified as a
spin instructor so those are the type of
success stories that we definitely love
to see and then as a final example going
back to this example I mentioned earlier
in that if you have a change in your DNA
we can detect that quite easily with
next-generation sequencing depending on
which type of change it is but if you
have a change in your RNA if we're
sequencing DNA we won't detect that and
so what that change can lead to a course
is an aberrant protein and so this is
another success story from the group at
Washington University in st. Louis and
it was published in The New York Times
and this was a case where there was a
change in RNA and it was a specific gene
that was mutated where the there was a
specific inhibitor for the gene that
lived that was mutated so sequencing the
DNA they weren't able to identify the
change but they used RNA sequencing to
see that they had significant
overexpression of that at messenger RNA
which was leading to been significantly
increased protein concentrations in
using that specific inhibitor they were
able to effectively treat this patient
and if you want to read more about that
it was published in The New York Times
so just to conclude so there's there's
been a lot of editorials talking about
genomics whether it's a pipe or hope and
so this was something that France and
Francis Collins had published at the
time that the human genome project was
was completed with an editorial from
2006 and so I really like this figure
where the enthusiasm cycle for a new
technology is what's shown and so if we
look at over time on the x-axis we
compare that with the level of
excitement on the y-axis and so you have
the initial idea followed by enthusiasm
and so you have this this peak where you
have a lot of height right followed very
quickly by a reality check and so you
see the period of disillusionment
following and then you you gradually
increase to really having the true
performance of an assay and I think that
this is really where we're at now with
with clinical next generation sequencing
where we're starting to see the
technological advances meeting
the clinical needs and that will only
continue to increase as we see
additional products come to come to
markets that it really do have it have
demonstrated clinical utility and
clinical benefit and so I'll conclude
here with some acknowledgments groups
that I've collaborated with both at the
University of Washington as well as
Washington University in st. Louis and I
would be happy to take any questions
that may be coming in through the Q&A
thank you very much dr. Lockwood for
bringing that informative presentation
to us before we get started with our
question and answer session I want to
remind the audience how they can submit
questions for you you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking the green
2 and 8 button at the lower level of the
presentation window and hopefully we'll
have some questions and we'll try to get
to them as many get to as many of them
as we can that was some definitely an
interesting presentation dr. Lockwood I
hadn't heard anything about this type of
sequencing and we do have our first
question marina from morphogenesis asks
are there clinically available panels
that screen how tumor cells escape the
immune system in addition to common to
more mutations for example ctla4 PDL one
that's a very interesting question and
so thank you for bringing it for
bringing it up so these these types of
treatments so it's for example anti PDL
one are really becoming more these
immunotherapies are becoming more
prevalent in cancer diagnostics and it's
definitely an exciting area that that
will have a significant benefit we're
starting to see this already in melanoma
in particular at this point there there
aren't there's certainly not any sort of
a commercial commercially available
package that's really able to identify
this there it's happening in their
research context
in so clinical laboratories similar to
how we've developed these in our
comprehensive tumor sequencing essays
clinical laboratories are really
developing their their own tools to look
at this so it's something we've seen
come out of the clinical trials of the
of a specific gaming of therapies but
there there is not a commercial product
that can be purchased at something that
would have to be developed to de novo
thank you for that answer is a good
question from our audience member about
this kind of technology I just going to
give our audience a minute to submit any
more questions that they have and we'll
watch the question queue for them um if
we don't have any further questions I'd
like to ask dr. Lockwood do you have any
final comments for the audience about
this topic and about where it's going in
the future I I'll just emphasize though
you've heard throughout my talk several
times I've talked about how exciting
this technology is I definitely think
that we're going to continue to see more
more growth in this area both as far as
more laboratories offering it as well
and commercial products that are coming
to market so I think that's something
that will will watch and be excited to
see continued to develop and as our
audience member has already asked it's
not only going to be in in the we
identify a mutation in that identifies a
treatment but I think we'll see
expansion beyond that as immunotherapy
comes more to market and it's really
going to be the integration of multiple
technologies that are going to lead us
do that to this and I think now hope not
hype but hope of precision cancer
therapeutics excellent hope not hype
that sounds fascinating I want to let
our audience know now that we don't have
any more questions that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through April first any of our audience
members who are here today will receive
an email from lab roots alerting them
when the webcast is available to replay
and we would invite you to share that
email among your colleagues who perhaps
could not make today's live event I want
to thank dr. Christina Lockwood again
for bringing us in from a
to us we hope to see you next time
goodbye thank you